is just past 10 GMT and we start with
rapidly developing news Israel has
launched an artillery attack against the
Lebanese border this comes just a day
after the Israeli Army concluded its
biggest assault on Janine in the
occupied West Bank in 20 years this
attack on Lebanon happened near the town
of farshuba in response it says to
earlier rocket attacks from the area its
military had initially said that they
were carrying out a routine mine
Explosion Israel and Lebanon are still
technically at war with United Nations
peacekeepers stationed at their border
will will have reaction from West
Jerusalem in a short while first though
let's go live to zainer Horror in Beirut
Zena fill in the details of what
happened and any information you might
have on why it happened
the moment there is a cautious calm it
was yet another cross-border fire
incident we've seen this happen quite
often really in the past few months it
has now been contained the Israeli Army
saying that it shelled the area from
which a rocket was launched from
Southern Lebanon into Israel yet there
is still no confirmation from Lebanon
whether from the Army whether from the
United Nations about that rocket attack
both sides really have been careful not
to risk a major flare-up so when Israel
strikes back they Strike Back In open
areas when Rockets are launched from
Lebanon they they avoid casualties
because both sides really have a lot to
lose if there is a major escalation but
clearly this is a message if you just
look at the timing Hezbollah has made it
clear the Lebanese group the armed group
that has fought with Israel in the past
it has made it clear time and time again
that Israel is facing a unit a unified
front the so-called resistance axis the
players of this resistance axis whether
it is Hamas and Gaza Hezbollah and
Lebanon other groups in Syria that if
there is an attack against one group or
one front then all fronts will open a
few days ago we saw Israel launch that
major attack against Janine in the West
Bank a day or two later we saw that
ramming and stabbing attack in Jerusalem
and then we saw a rocket being fired
from Southern Gaza excuse me Northern
Gaza into Southern Israel and then the
rocket that was fired from Southern
Lebanon into Israel so there's a new
military calculus a new military
strategy and that is the message that is
being sent to Israel today
reporting from Beirut thank you very
much let's go to Imran Khan who's in
West Jerusalem Imran pretty much the
same question to you which is based on
your information what happened and also
once the Israeli explanation for why it
happened
well there was some confusion actually
when the incident first took place
initial media reports initial reports
from the Army suggested that it was a
rocket that was fired then that was
quickly denied by the Israeli Army
speaking to Israeli Army Radio they said
actually these are just minefields that
uh an unexploded mine may have just
exploded but then the Israeli Army went
down to the scene they issued a
statement it's worth reading you a
little bit of it following the report
regarding the explosion adjacent
uh soldiers arrived at the scene it was
revealed that the launch was carried out
from Lebanese territory which exploded
adjacent to the Border in Israeli
territory in response the Army is
currently striking the area from which
the launch was carried out in Lebanese
territory so they eventually did confirm
it they fired about 15 artillery shells
into that empty field now this was a
short-range mortar not very powerful and
likely to be much more of a message than
try trying to strike anything now these
things as we've seen in Gaza and in
other places they're incredibly easy to
do doesn't require a huge amount of
Manpower two people tops they could get
into a field they put their mortar down
they fire it and they've they're gone as
quickly as they arrived so the Israeli
Army in proportional response they
needed to make a response so they've
just shelled their empty out area and
it's also telling that they haven't
actually told civilians to leave now
there have been no claims of
responsibility so far for this but if
you take a look at the mortar shelling
and that type of activity it's much more
likely going to be one of the local
groups within the area rather than say
uh Hezbollah when Hezbollah strike they
tend to hit things this probably just a
warning coming out of that area
um and the conference from one of the
local groups but that hasn't been
confirmed and you know but that's what
people are now talking about in the
media the artillery selling is now over
and it's likely that that's probably the
end of that for today certainly
Imran Khan thank you for the information
thank you for the context as well Imran
Khan reporting from West Jerusalem let's
go to Elias Farhat you are a military
analyst a former Lebanese Army General
and you're joining us now from Beirut we
appreciate your time thanks for joining
us on the program what do you make of
what happened this artillery shelling by
Israel
uh this sharing by Israel comes as a
response on what so-called a rocket or a
shell from Lebanese territories which
hits the
Border area and Jason to the Lebanese
territories and the occupied which
Israel considered as
an attack on its services and usually
Israel responds to the uh and in a
limited targets and and they are Keen
not to bomb civilians or houses just
only in the Arid area which happens now
so
the The
Rules of Engagement are really avoided
good by Israel and
Hezbollah as well because the discount
conflict is since Sunday and in this
area is restricted on this area only and
it expands so
I mean west or east the the
the situation is very expensive in the
area especially after Israel and next
the developing side of leisure
regardless of the United Nations the
radiation of the uh
Blue Line in 2000 and which was made it
clear that there is a Lebanese side from
and another is occupied side so the
situation is still sensitive and now
we're sorry if I could jump in oh wait
both our correspondents talked about
each side the Lebanese side the Israeli
side sending messages
um and you could argue this is how
Lebanon and Israel talk to each other
with what they're striking when they
strike where they strike how they strike
the amount of Firepower used how is this
message if we accept this premise how is
this message from Israel going to be
interpreted on the Lebanese side of the
Border
message by a small
which blew up in an Israeli territories
far so adjacent to the
and as I am also replies to this message
by bobbing
the uh this rocket was launched so this
messages between both sides but this
message
so that's
the
[Music]
the problem the problem
we see an escalation for this message
for more violence than the coming days
a next next thing they
they and the United Nations Forces that
it's not to do anything to uh
have the situation and the gather as it
was
yesterday I mean we are waiting we are
waiting this
[Music]
before another
more environment
Elias farhart former Lebanese Army
General thank you so much for joining us
on the program
foreign